PROFESSOR: Welcome to this
recitation on linearization.
So here we consider a
prey-predator system,
where we have x dot equals
x, factorizing 3 minus x,
minus x*y, and y dot equals
y factorizing 1 minus y,
plus x*y.
So here we can see that x is
the prey, because y is basically
feeding on it.
And y is the predator,
because feeding
on x gives a growth of
the predator species, y.
So here, because it's
a prey-predator system,
x and y are assumed
to be positive.
So you're asked to interpret
even further this system
and to find the critical points,
linearize and sketch the phase
portrait and then discuss what
your linearization tells you
about the behavior
of this system.
So why don't you pause
the video and take
a few minutes to do that.
I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
So I helped you already
for the first question.
We interpreted that x was the
prey and y was the predator.
The other thing
that you could see
is that this term here is
basically logistic growth.
So if we didn't have the
predator species around,
this species x of
prey would just
grow and eventually reach
a value that corresponds
to the saturation level.
And if we started with
a lot of prey, then
eventually they would
die off and go back
to that same carrying
capacity value
of prey in that environment.
Same thing here
for the predator.
We have a logistic growth, with
different growth coefficients.
And again, if we didn't
have the prey around,
we would just have
a logistic dynamic
for this species on its own.
But with the prey, we have
a growth of this species.
So that basically
ends the first part.
For the second part, we need
to find the critical points.
So how do we find
the critical points?
The critical points correspond
to basically f and g
equals to 0.
So f equal to 0 equals to g.
You see from f equals to 0 that
we can have either x equals 0,
if we factorize the
x in both terms,
and if x is not equal
to 0, then we end up
with y equals to 3 minus x.
For the second part,
we can also here,
if g equals to 0, factorize y.
And we get either y
equals to 0, or we
have that x is
equal to y minus 1,
where I just bring that
term to the other hand.
So the critical point would be
either of these two entries.
It would be, for example, x
equals to 0 and this entry,
which would give
us y equals to 1;
or we would have y
equals to 0, and then
this entry would give
us x equals to 3.
And then the last
combined case, where
we have these two entries,
which corresponds to 1 and 2,
if you do it.
So let's look now
at the stability
of the linearization of
the system around each one
of these critical points.
So what do we do to
linearize the system?
Very quickly, we need
to compute the Jacobian
around each critical
point-- and we're just
going to build a table after
to do that-- where we basically
have f, a derivative of f
around x, derivative of g
around x, derivative of f around
y, derivative of g around y,
all this evaluated at
the critical point.
And this corresponds to
basically linearizing
our nonlinear system,
because you see here
that there are a lot
of nonlinear systems,
and studying the stability
around the neighborhood
of the critical point,
like if it was basically
linear around there.
This method has its limitations,
and we'll discuss them later.
So first I'm going
to just here give you
the results of computation
that I did earlier,
where basically you can
repeat this computation.
But I don't want to spend too
much time with the algebra
here.
So we have four critical points.
(0,0), (0,1), (3,0), and (1,2).
So this is going to just replace
the values for the Jacobian.
So here you compute
basically the derivative
of f of x with respect to x.
And you evaluate this at
then the value of (0,0).
And so that would give
you [3,  0; 0, 1].
For this case, same thing.
We have the expression
for the Jacobian.
We evaluate it at
critical point (0,1).
And that gives us [2, 0; 1, -1].
For this one similarly, we
evaluate the Jacobian at (3,0).
And we get this Jacobian value.
And for this last
critical point,
we have this Jacobian value.
So now what's next?
So the Jacobian
basically gives us
the expression around
the critical point
to look at the system, like
if it was linear around there.
So from this point, we're
back to the linear methods
we learned before.
We need to compute the
eigenvalues of the Jacobian
around each critical point, and
then determine the structure
around each critical point
of the structure of basically
the phase portrait.
So what are the eigenvalues?
The eigenvalues are 3, 1,
and you can compute that
and verify for yourself.
Plus or minus root of 7i
and the whole thing over 2.
So here basically, we
have two real eigenvalues,
both positive.
So we're going to
have, basically,
an instability, unstable node.
And it's just basically
the local stability
around the critical point.
Here we would have one
positive, one negative.
So this is a saddle,
which would be unstable.
The -3, 4 would give
us another saddle.
And these complex
eigenvalues would basically
give us a spiral with
the real part going
to 0, with the real
part being negative.
So a spiral that's
stable, asymptotically.
So let's just do
the diagram here.
And I'll continue
the discussion.
So let's consider only the case
where x and y are positive,
because we're talking
about populations.
And let's place our
critical points.
So we have a first critical
point here at (0,0).
We have a second critical
point here at (0,1).
We have a third
critical point at (3,0),
and the last critical
point at basically (1,2),
or something around there.
So now, based on the information
we have on this table,
we have the eigenvalues.
We could also compute the
corresponding eigenvectors.
And you can compute that.
And I'm not going to get
into the details here,
but basically the values
of the eigenvectors
would be important to
give you, for example,
the direction of your spiral.
But we will do that on
the diagram as we go.
So here at the (0,0)
point is an unstable node.
So basically, the
solutions are going away
from this point in the x and y.
This point, (0,1) is a saddle.
So we basically are
on the ray here.
You would compute that the
eigenvector that corresponds
to this negative
eigenvalue would actually
be in the direction
[0,1] and would
converge toward this solution.
And you can compute that
the other eigenvector,
corresponding to
the eigenvalue 2,
would have a
direction this form.
So here we neglect
what's happening here,
but it would be
in this direction.
And the solutions would be
basically going away from here.
And we would have locally
something like that.
For this point,
which corresponds
to an unstable node,
basically the solution
would be going away.
For this point, which
corresponds to (3,0),
we have a saddle again,
which is unstable.
And here you can compute that
the eigenvector corresponding
to the negative
eigenvalue would basically
be parallel to the x-axis.
So it would have
coordinates (1,0).
And the eigenvector
corresponding
to the eigenvalue 4 would be
directed in this direction.
And basically, the solution
would be fleeing from there.
So locally, we would
have something like that,
like we did before.
So we'll complete the graph.
Now, let's focus on the
last critical point, (1,2).
So this point
corresponds to a spiral.
And it's a stable spiral
-- asymptotically stable,
because this
eigenvalue's negative.
So the solutions are
going toward this point.
And you can look at the lower
entry here of the matrix, which
is positive, which
means that we would
be going counterclockwise.
So we would have something there
would be looking like this,
going toward this point.
So that's roughly
what we would have
for the three critical points.
Am I missing one?
For the four critical points.
And so now we can
complete our diagram
by basically linking to
different localized phase
portraits together.
And so what will we have here?
So for example, we would
have a solution here
that would be escaping, if we
start in this neighborhood,
would be escaping from
this critical point.
But then eventually,
it would get attracted
by this other
critical point, which
when it enters its
basin of attraction,
given that it's asymptotically
stable would be attracted by it
and go here.
If we started from
a very high y-value,
we would be going down and
then eventually getting close
to this critical point.
That would then basically
cause this trajectory
to, again, escape and
go feed this spiral
by reaching the basin of
attraction of this point.
If we look at the
critical point (3,0),
then if we start with a
population x that is very large
and we approach this point, then
we would have a solution that
basically would eventually
continue parallel
to this ray of the unstable part
of the critical point (3,0),
follow this ray and
eventually basically
just be far more parallel
to this trajectory that
links this linear
(3,0) critical point
to the (1,2) critical point.
And so we can
complete the diagram
by having something like this.
Now for this point,
what do we have?
So for this point, we
also have the solutions
that would be basically
fleeing from the point (0,0),
and eventually could be
attracted to the spiral
as well.
So that we give
us then something
like this, a trajectory that
would be looking like that.
And basically these trajectories
And I'm not going to complete
the parts where y and x are not
positive.
So we can complete the phase
diagram of this nonlinear
system in this way.
So now, how do we
interpret this?
What does this mean?
Well, if we remind ourselves of
what this is actually modeling,
and if we just look
at, for example,
the different axes, what
does the y equals 0,
x equals 0 point mean?
It means that basically
we have 0 population
of prey, 0 of predator.
And so it makes sense
that we have basically
an unstable point here, an
unstable critical point,
because as soon as we add
one prey or one predator,
we would have an increase
of the prey population,
eventually the
predator would grow,
and so we would
have a solution that
basically escapes the area
around the critical point
(0,0).
What would happen if we just
looked at the axis y equals
to 0? y equals to 0
corresponds to dynamics
where we don't have the
predator population.
So the prey is just
living its life,
growing at logistic growth.
And so basically, it's attracted
by the carrying capacity
that would be here set at 3.
And so if we start
with a lot of prey,
eventually they die out until
they reach population 3.
And if we start with
not enough, they grow
and they reach population 3,
without the predator around.
Same thing for the
predator on its own.
Now if we put the
two together then
we have a spiral, which means
that we have oscillation.
If we have a lot of predators,
we have very few prey.
And eventually the predators
start dying off as well.
But then, because
they start dying off,
the prey population starts
increasing, which then gives
an increase of the predator.
So we get, eventually,
an oscillation that
goes to this attractor, (1,2),
where the system will stabilize
eventually, where we
would have, basically, one
prey for two predators.
So that ends the
interpretation of the system.
And the idea here
was to basically
use what we learned
for the linear systems,
in terms of the phase
portrait, and to see
how we can apply that
to the nonlinear cases,
after linearizing the
system around each one
of the critical points.
What I should also
mention here is
that in all these cases
that we looked at,
we had cases that were
structurally stable,
which means that in our
determinant-trace diagram,
we weren't at any
borderline case
where a little
perturbation could
make the structure around
the critical point change
radically.
So all these points are
structurally stable,
and the linearization
therefore is valid around them.
And that ends this recitation.